tout parce que bruno et je n'arrive pas
à comprendre pourquoi vous vous obstinez
vous refusez même le terme de violences
policières pour vous elles n'existent
pas ce que vous pourriez précisé cette
position je m'empresse de dire que je ne
la partage pas existé je ne la partage
pas je vais vous dire pourquoi pas ce
que vient ce policier ainsi un terme
générique qui ne veut rien dire car on
dit violences policières et on l'emploie
souvent les opposants à la police sont
ils sont pas aussi nombreux qu on l
imagine mais ils sont ils sont nourris
sont présents violences policières c'est
un terme générique qui englobe toute la
police et qui est des policiers qui
commettent des actes de violence la
personne ne nie pas plus et syndicats
papus le gouvernement que darmanin que
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
et que les médias ça c'est une chose
c'est un fait réel nous avait un peu
évolué un surnom n'ont jamais dit non
mais attendez eric j'ai jamais dit que
des policiers tous les arts et je parle
devant grecs joueront qui
unité-sgp-police tous les armes il ya
des policiers qui passe au trapèze bondi
de gpn il ya deux mille trente dossiers
je crois précisé marc inquiets de
fonctionnaires qui sont sanctionnés il
ya eu une quarantaine de révocation en
2019 je parle sous le contrôle du
responsable syndical donc je pense que
les policiers ne sont nullement non non
seulement l'administration la plus
sanctionnée ça il faut l'avouer les
violences si elles existent elles sont
sanctionnées on a l'exemple de ce qui
s'est passé avec michel c'est clair il
ya faut laisser faire d'abord la justice
a encore une fois ne faisons pas la
justice n'a rien dit que les médias avec
tout ce qu'on veut la justice doit
passer
mais la sanction est présente là où je
suis un petit peu plus partagés c'est
les cas retiration des deux
fonctionnaires de police